VERY MUCH.
IN THAT REPORT WE JUST HEARD HER
MENTION THE LABOR SECRETARY
EUGENE SCALIA HE JOINS US LIVE
FROM THE D.C. AREA.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU,
MR. SECRETARY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, YESTERDAY I
SPOKE ON THE PHONE WITH KANSAS
LABOR SECRETARY GARCIA AND THIS
STRIKES EVERYBODY.
HER FAMILY DOWN IN WICHITA HAS
HAD A RESTAURANT THERE FOR
DECADES.
THEY ARE CLOSED.
EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY
IS ON UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE STATE OF KANSAS AS YOU KNOW
HAS A VERY LOW RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT IN A REGULAR WEEK.
MAYBE 1300 WOULD APPLY.
OVER THE LAST WEEK, 55,000
APPLIED.
THEY HAVE HAD TO QUADREVION DO
YOU MEAN PELL THE CALL CENTER.
THIS IS ALL HANDS ON DECK AT THE
STATE LEVEL AS WELL AS THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO FILE UNEMPLOYMENT
CAN GET THEIR MONEY AND
ULTIMATELY GET THE STIMULUS AS
WELL, RIGHT?
>> YES.
THE STATES ARE WORKING VERY HARD
TO GET THESE PAYMENTS OUT.
AS YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE KEY
PROVISIONS IN THE CARES ACT,
WHICH THE PRESIDENT SIGNED TWO
WEEKS AGO.
WAS THIS ENHANCEMENT TO
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS THAT ARE ORDINARILY
MADE AVAILABLE BY THE STATES.
ADDITIONAL $600 A WEEK THAT’S
BEING MADE AVAILABLE.
AND THE STATES ARE WORKING VERY
HARD TO MAKE THAT MONEY
AVAILABLE.
I THINK NOW SEVEN STATES ARE
MAKING THAT AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LOST WORK AS WELL AS TO
GIG ECONOMY WORKERS.
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AREN’T
NORMALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION.
THIS LEGISLATION DOES MAKE T.
AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO.
AINSLEY: TALK ABOUT THE
BOUNCEBACK.
WE HEARD THE PRESIDENT SAYING
THE ECONOMY WILL TURN AROUND.
DO YOU AGREE WITH HIM AND HOW
ARE WE GOING TO DO THAT?
>> WELL, I DO AGREE.
I SHARE THAT OPTIMISM.
THESE ARE SUCH CHALLENGING TIMES
FOR WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
THE PROGRAM THAT WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT IS ONE REFLECTION
OF THE EFFORTS HERE IN
WASHINGTON TO ADDRESS IT BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, I AM MINDFUL OF
JUST HOW STRONG OUR ECONOMY WAS
FIVE WEEKS AGO.
YOU KNOW, AT THE START OF MARCH,
WE PUT OUT ONE OF THE STRONGEST
JOBS REPORTS WE HAVE SEEN IN
THIS COUNTRY IN 50 YEARS.
THAT’S WHERE WE WERE.
THAT’S WHERE WE WANT TO GET BACK
TO.
AS I MENTIONED LAST NIGHT WHEN I
SPOKE AT THE BRIEFING, WE HAD A
BLUE COLLAR BOOM AND NOW WE WANT
A BLUE COLLAR BOUNCEBACK.
THINK WE STILL HAVE THE
FUNDAMENTALS THERE OUR ECONOMY
IS HURTING NOW NOT BECAUSE OF
UNDERLYING WEAKNESS IN THE
ECONOMY BUT HEALTH EMERGENCY.
WE NEED TO TACKLE THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN SO GOOD AT URGING YOUR
VIEWERS TO TAKE THESE MEASURES
TO BEAT THE VIRUS.
BUT THEN WE DO WANT TO GET BACK
TO WORK.
AND I THINK WE HAVE THE
FOUNDATION, THE FUNDAMENTAL AND
THE PRESIDENTIAL POLICIES IN
PLACE TO BE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THAT RECOVERY.
BRIAN: SO, MR. SECRETARY, WE SEE
DENMARK BEGIN TO GET BACK UP
ONLINE.
AUSTRIA GET BACK ONLINE, GERMANY
GET BACK ONLINE.
TAIWAN IS BACK ONLINE.
SINGAPORE IS BACK ONLINE.
ARE YOU STUDYING THOSE COUNTRIES
TO SEE HOW TO DO IT EVEN THOUGH
WE ARE SO MUCH BIGGER AND WITH
SUCH DIVERSITY?
WHERE -- WHAT MODEL ARE YOU
LOOKING AT FOR AMERICANS GETTING
BACK TO WORK?
>> WELL, WE ARE CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES
HAVE DONE AND LOOKING AT WHAT
THIS COUNTRY HAS DONE IN THE
PAST, TOO.
WE LOOK BACK 100 YEARS AGO
DEALING WITH THE SPANISH FLU.
THERE ARE LESSONS TO BE LEARNED
THERE WE KNOW A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
FIRST, THAT DISCIPLINE RIGHT NOW
REMAINS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
WE KNOW THAT WE WILL NEED TO GET
BACK BEFORE THIS VIRUS IS
ENTIRELY GONE FROM AMONG US.
AND WE HAVE TO PLAN FOR THAT.
WE KNOW THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE
SAME DATE IN EVERY LOCATION.
THAT WE’RE ALL BACK TO WORK.
WE WILL NEED TO PLAN
ACCORDINGLY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN’T
WAIT TOO LONG.
WE WANT TO BOUNCE BACK.
IT DOES GET HARDER THE LONGER
PEOPLE ARE KEPT FROM WORK.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THAT IN THE
BALANCE AS WELL.
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
STEVE: SURE, AS LABOR SECRETARY,
YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND, REGARDING THAT STORY IN THE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THIS
MORNING THAT APPARENTLY THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE PRESIDENT IN
PARTICULAR, WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
ESSENTIALLY AMERICAN BUSINESS
REOPEN, MAYBE IN STAGES BY
MAY 1st.
BUT THERE ARE GOING TO BE HOT
SPOTS, IT CAN’T BE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL YEP, WE ARE OPEN FOR
BUSINESS AGAIN.
EXPLAIN AS MUCH AS CAN YOU
WHAT’S GOING ON BEHIND THE
SCENES TO GET US TO THAT PLACE.
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
TO THIS.
THE HEALTH COMPONENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY IS CRITICAL TO GET
RIGHT.
THE MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE TO TIDE WORKERS OVER
ARE SO IMPORTANT TO THEM
INDIVIDUALLY.
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM,
WHICH YOU TALKED ABOUT A MOMENT
AGO FOR SMALL BUSINESS IS ONE OF
THE THINGS IN THIS RECENT
LEGISLATION THAT I LIKE MOST
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES IT PROVIDE
INCOME TO WORKERS DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME IT KEEPS THEM
DIED TO THEIR EMPLOYER.
SO THAT WHEN WE ARE READY TO
REOPEN, THAT RELATIONSHIP STILL
EXISTS.
THAT’S SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS AN INTEREST
IN EXTENDING THAT PROGRAM.
AND THEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF PEOPLE
WHEN THEY RETURN TO WORK.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOKS AFTER.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO US NOW AT THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT AND AS WE
REOPEN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT’S
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT’S SAFE AND
HEALTHY.
AINSLEY: MR. SECRETARY, THERE
WAS HEADLINE THIS MORNING SAYING
SOME FOLKS, SOME AMERICANS ARE
GOING TO GET THOSE STIMULUS
CHECKS TODAY.
CANCAN YOU UPDATE US ON WHEN PEO
WILL GET THAT MONEY?
>> THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT STREAMS OF RELIEF
COMING.
FIRST, AS I JUST MENTION, THERE
IS PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM.
AND THERE IS MORE THAN I THINK
140 BILLION IN LOANS ALREADY
APPROVED THROUGH THAT PROGRAM.
AND THOSE LOANS ARE NOW BEING
MADE AVAILABLE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
>> THAT WILL CONTINUE OVER TIME.
THEN WE HAVE PAYMENTS COMING
FROM INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE.
I BELIEVE THOSE WILL BE COMING
NEXT WEEK IS WHAT SECRETARY
MNUCHIN HAS SAID.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE ARE THESE
STEPPED UP UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PAYMENTS GOING TO
PEOPLE WHO, UNFORTUNATELY, ARE
OUT OF WORK.
THOSE ALREADY HAVE STARTED IN
SOME STATES.
AND WE’LL HAVE MORE STATES
COMING ONLINE IN THE DAYS AND
WEEKS AHEAD.
BRIAN: MR. ALICIA SECRETARY I
KNOW THIS IS MOWSEST MOSTLY
TREASURY.
PUT OUT MONEY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND I KNOW THEY ARE
GRATEFUL.
TOUGH UNDERSTAND SOME OF THESE
RESTAURANTS AND HEALTH CLUBS THE
75-25 DOESN’T WORK OUT.
IF THEY HAVE TO GIVE 75% OF THE
MONEY TO LABOR, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE ANY MONEY TO PAY
THEIR BILLS AND PAY THEIR RENT
AND PAY THEIR LEASE AND PAY FOR
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY RENT.
SO IF THE MONEY IS THERE, THERE
HAS GOT TO BE FLEXIBILITY GIVEN
TO THE BANKS TO ALLOW SMALL
BUSINESS TO USE IT BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW, IF THEY ARE GOING TO PUT
ALL THAT MEN TO LABOR, THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE A BUSINESS TO
GO BACK TO.
SO DO YOU SEE SOME FLEXIBILITY
THERE?
>> -THINK TREASURY DEPARTMENT
AND SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION WHICH HAVE BEEN
RUNNING THIS PROGRAM HAVE SHOWN
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY.
THERE WERE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE APPLICATION FORM MADE EARLY
ON THAT MADE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO APPLY.
I JUST THINK THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN FUNCTIONING EXTRAORDINARILY
WELL.
ITS BIGGEST CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
REALLY ITS POPULARITY.
BRIAN: NOT IN THOSE TWO AREAS.
THESE RESTAURANT OWNERS CAN’T
LIVE WITH 75% GOING TO LABOR.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE DON’T WANT
THEIR PART TIME JOBS BACK.
SO, YOU CAN’T GIVE THEM THE
MONEY AND TELL THEM TO GIVE IT
TO PEOPLE THAT DON’T WANT THE
JOBS AND THEN ASK THEM TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON AND TURN UP WITH A
DIMINISHED SEATING CAPACITY WHEN
THEY COME BACK.
IT’S NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> WELL, WE WILL KEEP LOOKING
FOR THE RIGHT BALANCE THERE AS
YOU SAY, THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION TREASURY ARE
RUNNING THAT PROGRAM.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE LABOR
DEPARTMENT THOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH WORKERS, THE BUSINESS TO
COME BACK BUT ALSO TO HAVE THOSE
WORKERS STILL TIED TO THEM AND
KEEPING THOSE STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS IS REALLY GOING TO
BE VERY IMPORTANT TO GETTING THE
ECONOMY GOING AGAIN.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT IT.
IS GREAT TO HAVE THE SECRETARY
OF LABOR FROM THE UNITED STATES